hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to an
edition of ask Evan
in today's episode I'm going to answer a
question from one of my newsletter
readers for jeath who is opening up a
gym he's he's managing it and he wanted
my advice on how to make it profitable
it's in its first year and he's kind of
struggling to get it going so thank you
for the question
from my experience with gyms at least
here in Canada the first challenge is
getting people to come into the door so
what a lot of businesses here will do a
lot of the gyms here is partner up with
local retailers and give them a
commission for when they refer people to
come into the gym so they'll have little
boxes at the retail outlets and you know
you can sign up there leave your contact
information somebody will call you and
they get a commission a lot of times
that somebody does come up and sign up
with the gym so that's one way to do it
direct mail another really common way to
do it I try to look at how can you get
involved in the community and how can
you either sponsor or get involved with
different events around your community
that are that are related to fitness and
activity people are going on a run or
there's a wireless campaign to try to
get involved in those things and be seen
in the community as a leader I think the
bigger challenge is getting people to
stay and like one of my favorite ways to
get more business is to really wow your
customers and get them to keep coming
back and then also bring their friends
right a referred customer is going to
spend more with you be more loyal ask
less questions and definitely a lot less
headaches and dealing with brand-new
customers who have no point of contact
with you yet so I definitely focus on
wowing your customers and I think it's
hard with gyms because a lot of times
people might come in in January and sign
up because you know New Year's
resolution and they want to you know
lose the weight that they gained over
the holidays and then you know within
the next month everybody drops off so if
people aren't coming back then it's
harder to get them to sign up again and
on
basis and they're not going to bring
their friends along to to come and try
out the generator so a couple of ideas
that might help you first you don't want
to have a newsletter so get people on
the immunes letter have either weekly or
monthly newsletter goes out and has lots
of valuable information and tips and
ideas and resources to help them get you
know the type of body that they want not
too much emotional stuff but a lot of
value add you can promote you know the
new classes you have coming up things
like that but make sure every newsletter
has a lot of value on content that
people look forward to receiving from
from you on a regular basis the second
thing is having classes and you want to
have interesting things that people want
to come back to as a added bonus to
becoming part of the gym and maybe even
make it that they can bring a friend to
it or either a free price or really
discounted price where you can bring
your friend once for free because you
want people to bring their friends feel
like it's a comfortable environment and
hopefully the final set up so if you
have a Zumba class or karate class at
lasting eight weeks nine weeks maybe
they can bring their friend for free to
the first you know five classes and gets
them hooked and then you know afterwards
they'd have to set up a membership you
want to make it easy for people to be
able to bring their friends refer them
and make it a fun experience now
somebody's coming with their friend
they're more likely to stick with it
then if somebody's coming by themselves
it's gonna is that challenge how do I
get people to come back you know after
that motivation in January is gone
another thing you might want to do is
try to create some videos just like this
and you can answer questions from people
maybe not you if you're not kind of the
expert on personal fitness but get some
of your trainers or your class seekers
to answer questions from your customers
and think about the most common
questions that are always asked and the
goal here is to be seen as not only the
experts but also really friendly people
and people that you want to go and learn
from so if I was watching a video of
somebody who's a karate expert and I
really wanted to learn
but maybe didn't have the courage to do
I didn't know if it was from me or not
but there were these videos that were
really helpful and and valuable and the
person seemed really knowledgeable and
friendly and I know that he's in my area
I'm probably gonna go and sign up and
check out a class and so that's a great
way to be able to connect with your
community and showcase your staff and
your your trainers and your your
teachers as experts and friendly people
and put your gym in a really positive
light then you can promote that you know
promote that on your signage motive and
any sponsorship deals that you do get
people coming and watch the videos and
the more they watch it and the more they
like what they see and the more time
they spend watching the videos the more
likely they're going to want to come and
sign up and keep coming back to the
classes that you have so hopefully
there's a few ideas that can help you
you know solve that challenge those of
you watching if you like the video
please give it a thumbs up I'd also love
to hear what you have to think about it
if you want to leave a comment under the
video or if you have another question
for your business feel free to leave it
in a comment section below I always read
those and try to respond to as many as I
can so thank you and I'll see you on the
next episode
you